You're going to disappoint us so we don't jump for joy.
today,
because the first thing we want to say
is that ETA and the Catalan separatist party
They have won the elections
and that the Spaniards
we are losing them
for a long time.
Spaniards loyal to our homeland,
to the unity that we defend freedoms,
we are moving backward positions
for too long
for complicity
of 1 A large part of the National political class
that we have heard over the last few times.
said that it was necessary to include
to Bildu on the future of the institutions,
which we have seen vote
in the congress of deputies
against the illegalization of Bildu